قال مفوض السلم والامن ان لدى المجموعه
اسسا قانونيه للتدخل في النيجر وانها لا
تحتاج لموافقه مجلس الامن الدولي لتنفيذ
ذلك التدخل واضاف انه اذا حدث تدخل عسكري
في النيجر فسيكون هناك ما ينقلب على
المجلس العسكري من داخل الجيش ياتي هذا
بالتزامن مع تحذير موسكو من ان اي تدخل في
النيجر سيزعزع الاستقرار فيه وفي المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الرسائل التي
تحملها تصريحات مفوض السلم والامن
بالاكواس بشان التدخل العسكري في النيجر
في هذا التوقيت وما قيمه التدخل الروسي من
مغبه ذلك التدخل في ضوء هذه التصريحات ثم
على اي نحو يمكن ان تتفاعل تصريحات مسؤول
ايكواس والتحذير الروسي بشان التدخل
العسكري في النيجر وما النتائج المتوقعه
لاي تدخل ان حدث بعد هذه التصريحات ثم
نبحث الى اين تتجه هذه الازمه في النيجر
في ضوء مواقف القوى الكبرى ودول الجوار
الافريقيه منها وما فرص تسويتها في ظل
تباعد مواقف المعنيين بها داخليا وخارجيا
[موسيقى]
على خلفيه جدل محتدم بشان تدخل عسكري
محتمل تقول مجموعه ان قاده جيوشها
سيجتمعون الاسبوع المقبل لمناقشته بعد ان
دعت المجموعه لتفعيل فوري لقوتها
الاحتياطيه قرر برلمان ايكوواس وبصوره
مفاجئه عقد جلسه طارئه عبر تقنيه الاتصال
المرئي لمناقشه تطورات السياسيه الاخيره
في النيجر بحسب مراسل الجزيره تطور يتزامن
مع تصريحات لمفوض السلم والامن في اكواس
عبد الفتاح موسى قال فيها ان لدى المجموعه
اسسا قانونيه للتدخل في النيجر وانها لا
تحتاج لموافقه مجلس الامن الدولي من اجل
تنفيذه وتابع موسى انه اذا حدث تدخل عسكري
في النيجر فسيكون هناك من ينقلب على
المجلس العسكري من داخل الجيش النيجري
واشار موسى الى ان قاده الجيش لم يرفض
حكومه الرئيس عليه وانهم دعموا الانقلاب
فقط من اجل تجنب اراقه الدماء
تصريحات المسؤول الرفيع في ايكواس تصادم
بشكل مباشر تحذيرا من موسكو هذه المره
التي وصف موقفها من الانقلاب وصف او طبعا
الانقلاب في النيجر وصف بالغامض من مغبه
اي تدخل عسكري في هذا البلد فقد قالت
موسكو ان اي تدخل عسكري لتسويه الازمه في
النيجر قد يؤدي الى زعزعه الاستقرار في
منطقه الساحل والصحراء روسيا وفي بيان
لوزاره خارجيتها دعت الى تجنب هذا النوع
من التدخل في النيجر لانه قد يؤدي الى
مواجهه طويله بحسب وصفها لكن وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه اعربت عن دعمها لجهود
مجموعه التي تهدف الى ايجاد سبل سلميه
للخروج من الازمه في النيجر
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو
السفير اندري
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس ومن
نورس الدكتور كاميرون كبير الباحثين
بالمركز الافريقي في المجلس الاطلسي اهلا
بكما ضيفي الكريمين وابدا بضيف من موسكو
السيد اندري لاساله عن هذا التحذير
الروسي من مغبه التدخل العسكري وتاثير كل
ذلك على مجمل منطقه الساحل والصحراء ما
الذي نفهم من هذا التحذير الروسي
انه ليس هناك اي ضروره لاي تدخل خارجي
شعب النيجر شعب بالغ وهم يقرون بانفسهم ما
الذي ينبغي القيام به من ناحيه السياسيه
ممكن
التعاون معهم ونعرض عليهم وجهات نظرنا
وجهه نظاره الغربي وامريكا ولكن
ليس هناك طرق اخرى غير الطريقه السلميه
للتعامل معهم
واننا نعارض الى حد كبير اي محاوله
قيامه قوات عسكريه بالتدخل اذا ما حصل اي
تدخل
فان هذا هذا امر غير جيد واننا سنفكر بمدى
ضروره
التعاون مع النيجرين ونقرر ما الذي سنقوم
به
للتعامل مع
هذا النوع من التطور اذا ما حصل هل معنى
ذلك ان موسكو لن تقبل اي تدخل عسكري ليس
فقط كموقف سياسي ودبلوماسي وانه يمكن
لبوسكو ان يكون لها دور في حال اي تدخل
عسكري
الى حد كبير نعم
انه لو حصل اي تدخل عسكري وخاصه باستخدام
قوات الفرنسيه او اي قوات من دوله غربيه
فاننا سيكون لدينا رد فعل ربما سيكون رد
فعل
باشكال اخرى اثناء قلت قبل ايام بانه كان
هناك وفد من الجزائر التقينا بهم
واننا نتعاون مع الدول العربيه فيما يتعلق
بتطورات الموقف في النيجر سيد كاميرا حتى
الان الموقف الامريكي يرجح ويدفع باتجاه
الحل الدبلوماسي في النيجر اخر تصريحات
الاكواس تقول ان التحضيرات لعمل عسكري على
قدم وساق حتى حديث ربما عن كيفيه التدخل
العسكري لن يكون حربا سيكون عمليه اقرب
الى عمليه جراحيه ومراهنه على انه داخل
الجيش النيجري من بامكانه ان يكون جزء او
من هذه العمليه العسكريه وبالتالي ماذا عن
الموقف الامريكي فضل هذا التصاعد باتجاه
الحل العسكري
تدعم موقف الاكواس منذ البدايه طبعا
واشنطن لديها مجموعه خاصه بها من المصالح
الامنيه في النيجر لابد من حمايتها وكذلك
تحاول الدعم
الديمقراطيه واصوات الحكم الديمقراطي بصرف
النظر عن اي اسباب قدمها انقلابيون او هل
ان الرئيس كان ليس لديه شعبيه ام لا كل
ذلك ليس مهم لا يمكننا في البلاد هذا
الدستور اهمله
واعتقدنا واشرطه مثل صنع الاتحاد الافريقي
ومثل اتحاد الاوروبي كلهم
دعموا دعما كاملا الحكم الديمقراطي في
بلاد والسؤال هو ما هو
التدخل العسكري دعما للديمقراطيه وحتى في
هذا المجال اعتقد هناك توافق كبير واسع
بان الدبلوماسيه يجب
المقام الاول لكن
قد تكون
نتائج نتائج تعود الديمقراطيه فهنا تفضل
التدخل العسكري طيب ولكن وفارس وغيرها
منقول خارجيه لا تستخدم هذا التهديد بل
ولا حتى يتحدثون عن تدخل العسكري هذا
اعتقد يتركونه الافارقه هم يقررونهم ساعود
لك السيد لاسالك عن هذا المعطى الجديد
وهذا التحذير من قبل الجانب الروسي كيف
تقراه ولكن دعني استقبل ضيفي وارحب بضيفي
من مدينه اصابه النيجيريه كاين ايف
المستشار السابق لمجموعه ايكواس سيد كاين
كيف وجدت هذا التحذير الروسي في ظل هذا
التصعيد من قبل بان عملا عسكريا يجري
الترتيب له في النيجر كيف وجد هذا التحذير
الروسي وتاثيره على اي خطوه عسكريه من قبل
انا حقيقه لا اود ان اسميه تهديدا روسيا
لان روسيا اوضحت تماما حقيقه ان
الدبلوماسيه واسلوب الحوار هو الذي يجب ان
يتم اتباعه هناك الكثير من
النيجرين الذين هم ضد التدخل القضيه ليست
قضيه النيجر فحسب هل هي قضيه غرب افريقيا
ككل لا احد يشك في مشروعيه اي عمل عسكري
لان هذا العمل متفق عليه
بموجب ميثاق
للاكواس
لان النيجر تقع في
ملتقى ثلاثه اطراف
ارهابيه تنظيم الدوله والقاعده
نحن نعلم ايضا بان هناك
تزايدا في المشاعر ضد
الهيمنه الفرانكفونيه في غرب افريقيا نحن
على علم بذلك لكننا ايضا نعلم ان هناك
حالات من الفساد من قبل بعض الرؤساء ونحن
نحاول ان نتعامل معهم في ظل مصالح
النفط والغاز وغيرها من المعادن نخشى ان
تحول النيجر الى السودان اخرى هذه قضيه
ليست قضيه نيجيريا والنيجر بحسب القضيه
الاكوس لا يمكن ان نقف مكتوب فيها الايدي
ونصبح للموقف ان يتحول الى
مجازر مثل ما حدث في رواندا في طبعا هناك
من الحدود بين نيجيريا والنيجر طيب نقاط
نقاط مهمه ذكرتها سيد كين نقاط مهمه دعني
ضيفي في موسكو السيد
اذا كان اي تدخل عسكري قد حصل في اطار
منظمه اقليميه هي منظمه ايكواس النيجر هي
جزء من هذه المنظمه قد يتساءل سائل لماذا
تحذر موسكو البعيده من اي عمل عسكري تقوم
به منظمه اقليميه جزء منها
نحن لا نفهم لماذا الدول الاخرى يحق لها
ان تفرض ارادتها
على هذا البلد وايضا شاهدنا
مثلا بوركينا
هم يدعمون الحكام الحاليين في نيجر
والجزائر يعرضونهم وبالتالي ليس هناك صوت
موحد حتى في هذه المنظمه شبه الاقليميه
ولكن الامر قد يكون ربما سيكون نفس نفس
الظاهره التي كانت قبل السنوات عندما حصل
في مصر عندما كانت هناك انقلاب على يد
جمال عبد الناصر ثم
هو اصبح الرئيس والزعيم الوحيد لمصر وكذلك
بالنسبه للمسكريري الذي كان مرتين رئيسه
مجموعه عسكريه ثم اصبح الرئيس
لعده سنوات وبالتالي في افريقيا كل شيء
ممكن وبالتالي لذلك نعتقد بان شعب النيجر
هو الذي ينبغي ان يقرر مصيره بنفسه واننا
نعارض اي والحد الكبير اي تدخل اي تدخل
اي تدخل
ونعتبر ذلك فرصه لنا
لنتحرك ونرد على ذلك بشكل مباشر اذا محصله
مثل هذا التطور كيف ذلك
باي وسيله
نعم اذا كان ذلك ضروريا
من السابق لاواني الحديث عن ذلك لكن
بالتاكيد اذا حصل
اللجوء استخدام القوه
فان يستخدمون القوه طبعا يؤدي الى ارتفاع
الاستخدام القوم قبل الاخرين وبالتالي نحن
ضد مساله بدء القوه استخدام القوه بدء
ضيفي من كارولينا الدكتور كاميرون رغم ان
واشنطن في وقت سابق قالت بان لا علاقه او
تاكد بان لا علاقه
لفاكنر بالانقلاب الذي حدث في النيجر ما
الذي قد يضيفه هذا التصريح الروسي هذا
التحذير الروسي لاي عمل عسكري في النيجر
للحسابات الامريكيه هذه المره في النيجر
اعتقد ان واشنطن تدركه
ان مجموعه فاك النار هي في المنطقه فعلا
وهي موجوده على الارض وتحاول التوسع
وتوسع منطقتها في المنطقه تحل وصوله الى
تشاد وفي فصل وصلت السودان وفي الجمهور
افريقيا الوسطى وهي تحاول الربط كل هذه
النقاط عبره
افريقيا الوسطى وان تفهم ايضا انه عندما
هناك خلل في الاستقرار السياسي وهناك ضعف
فان ذاك فاك نار يمكن يدخل ويستفيدوا من
ذلك لخلق علاقات ولذلك فان واشنطن مهتمت
جدا بضمان
وابقاء الحكم الديمقراطي في النيجر ولكن
رغم ذلك فان تشعر بقلق شديد حول هذا النوع
من المنافسه بين القوه
اعتقد انه سيكون مرفوظا تماما لروسيا ان
تقبل او تتدخل فيما يتعلق باي عمل عسكري
في النيجر في الاسبوع الماضي
سمعنا ان التصريحات التي
صدرت عن الجانب الافريقي
وايما تقوم به روسيا فنحن في افريقيا
قادرون تماما على
التعامل مع ما حصل ومع التهديدات
الارهابيه
وبغير من المخاطر ويجب ان يسمحوا لنا ان
نقوم بذلك امريكا والغرب
يحترمان افريقيا والقوه
الموجوده لدينا وقد حصل ذلك في الكاميرون
وجامبيا من قبل
ويجب ان لا نسمح بالتحول النيجر الى سودان
اخرى معنى ذلك بان التصريحات الروسيه لن
تؤثر في اي خطه عسكريه قد يقربها
[موسيقى]
في اخر التصريحات من قبل الايكواس عن نوع
العمليه العسكريه ان تمت في النيج لانها
لن تكون حاربا ستكون اقرب الى عمليه
جراحيه بها تصحيح الوضع عسكريا الرساله
الموجهه للجيش بان الجيش ربما ليس باكمله
جزء من هذا الانقلاب في حال ما حدث
التغيير فان الجيش لم وافق على الانقلاب
فقط حقنا للدماء هل هذا كافي لطمانه الدول
الرافضه لاي تدخل عسكري ان الحرب لن تكون
هناك حرب وانما عمليه عسكريه جراحيه
لا يزال في
خانه التكهنات لان الامر
ليس متعلقه
باي تدخل
والتوسع في اندر لماذا نفعل ذلك نحن لدينا
ما يكفي من الموارد نحن لا نريد حربا
بارده لا نريد انهيار لدوله الامر
والقانون لا نريد للارهابيين ان يفرضوا
هيمنتهم لا نريد ذلك لمنطقتنا ونحن قادرون
تماما على التعامل مع الموقف تعاملنا معه
في غامبيا عندما
تدخلت قواتنا المعارضه اختفت
معظم اهل النيجر يريدون السلام وهم يدركون
تماما ان ان الحرب التي يريدها قاده
الانقلاب منهما يخوضوها لن يخوضوها عندما
يتدخل الاخوه العسكريه
الاخرون سيتخلل عن القتال وهم
حتى لا تكون هناك فضائك كما حصل في رواندا
ضيفي من السفير اندري باك لانوف منذ بدايه
الانقلاب كان يوصف الموقف الروسي
الالغامض بعد هذا التصريح هل يمكن القول
بان شيئا فشيئا بدا يتجلى الموقف الحقيقي
لموسكو لطبيعه ما جرى وما قد يجري في
النيجر
مازال ندرس الموقف واذكركم بانه خلال فتره
طويله من الزمن لم تكن لدينا سفاره في
النيجر وبالتالي
نحن حذرون جدا ولكننا نصر على انه لا
ينبغي هناك اي محاوله لخروق ضغوط خارجيه
ولا اي محاوله لتاثير على
القاده العسكريين نحن ضد ذلك واننا نحذر
انه اتخذ مثل هذه الاجراء ضد النيجر فاننا
فاننا سنعيد النظر في موقفنا وربما نتخذ
اجراءات اكثر شده ضد هذه
العوامل الخارجيه نحن نعتقد ان الشعب
النيجيري هو الذي ينبغي ان يقرر مصيره عن
طريق الحوار الداخلي في
حسابات موسكو كما تراها سيد اندري
باكلانوف دعني اسال ضيفي من كارولينا
الدكتور كارتون عن الحسابات الامريكيه
الان بين ما ذكرته من حسابات تتعلق
بفاجنر وما تقوم به عن حسابات الدبلوماسيه
او الدفع بالحاله الدبلوماسي من قبل
واشنطن للحل في النيجر وحسابات
ما المقاربه الامريكيه في ظل هذا الملف
وتطوراته باختصار دكتور كاميرون
تدعم وتدعم في كل تصريحاته وموقفها
وايدتها واشنطن ونحن لا نعرف ان كانت
واشنطن
هل انها تقدم اي تطمينات خاصه بان استقدم
المزيد من الدعم او دعم العسكري او انواع
اخرى من الدعم لقش شاهدنا ان وزير
الخارجيه يواصل بالحديث عن الرئيس بازون
واتصل بالرئيس يوسف ويحاول التواصل مع
القاده العسكرينه في النيجر وبالتالي
فواشن تواصل بضغوطها الدبلوماسيه الخاصه
بها لكن كل ذلك هو دعما لما تقوم قامت فيه
ليكوس وقالته الاكواز والواشنطن ستواصل
دعمها
لحل بقياده افريقيه ولا اعتقد ان شكرا
مستعد للتقديم اي دعم عسكري اذا ما وصل
الامر لذلك ادركنا
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]